foreign
[Music]
it's the weekend so it's high time for
news about your favorite movies and
Series this time around we have yet
another fast and furious movie the
casting of the leading role in Superman
Legacy and the release dates of the
Marvel series Echo and Loki season 2. in
addition there was the first real teaser
for the Five Nights at Freddy's movie
and news about the next Hellboy last but
not least Arnold Schwarzenegger
commented on the next Terminator sequel
as you can see there was a lot going on
so without further Ado let's begin with
keynotech news
the video game Five Nights at Freddy's
was released almost nine years ago and
has since produced numerous sequels
shortly after the launch of the game
series there were discussions about a
film adaptation which has been confirmed
several times in recent years but whose
production progress only slowly now
there is finally the first official
teaser for the horror film adaptation
after a leak recently went viral showing
the first clips of the upcoming Five
Nights at Freddy's trailer the horror
games fan Community proved themselves
United and for the most part didn't even
watch The Unwanted reveal or talk about
the scenes shown as we recorded last
week game creator Scott cawthon
expressed his gratitude to the loyal
fans on Reddit who can now finally enjoy
the first official teaser a look at the
video reveals the prevailing mood of the
film which seems to be very close to the
original the focus is on security guard
Mike Schmidt who gets the task of
working the night shift at the popular
Freddy Fazbear's pizzeria in the process
he quickly realizes that the
animatronics serve a greater purpose
than giving kids fun during the day at
Night Freddy Fazbear and his friends
become terrifying machines that require
a lot of stamina for Mike as he
gradually gets to the bottom of their
peculiar Behavior a closer look at the
teaser reveals a few Easter eggs above
all the set and some scenes are a
one-to-one replica from the game even
Freddie himself looks as though he's
taken straight from one of the video
games which should Delight many fans the
music at the end of the teaser is also
familiar which begs the question of
whether the soundtrack might also
originate from the game the starring
role of Mike Schmidt will be filled by
Future Man actor Josh Hutcherson as also
seen in the teaser you actress Elizabeth
lale and Mary Stuart Masterson are also
involved the villain and animatronic
Creator William Afton is played by Bosch
in Scream actor Matthew Willard Emma
Tammy who has already acquired
experience in the genre with the Western
horror of the wind is in charge of
directing the theatrical release for The
Five Nights at Freddy's movie is
scheduled for October 27 2023 so you can
look forward to the long-awaited spooky
film right on time for Halloween
finally Marvel fans know more as the
release dates for Loki season 2 and the
new Echo series have been announced at
the same time there are two
particularities in the world of MCU
shows the popular Loki series starring
Tom Hiddleston and Owen Wilson will be
resumed on Disney Plus on October 6th it
is thus the first MCU series ever to be
given a second season in addition to the
two stars Sophia dimartino will also
return as the female form of Loki
likewise there is believed to be a role
for KI Hai Kwan who has recently won an
Academy Award for everything everywhere
all at once a return of Jonathan Majors
currently on trial as a variant of Kang
is uncertain as with the first season
Rick and Morty writer Eric Martin was in
charge of the script This Time Justin
Benson and Aaron Moorhead who have
already worked on Moon Knight took over
the directing the Hawkeye spin-off Echo
tells the story of death assassin Maya
Lopez played by Aqua Cox Daredevil fans
can rejoice as well as Vincent diatrio
and Charlie Cox also joined the cast as
Kingpin and Daredevil plus this is a
first for Marvel all episodes of echo
will be released at the same time on
November 29th 2023 with secret Invasion
premiering on June 21st that will be all
the MCU Series this year ironheart and
the Wanda Vision spin-off Agatha coven
of chaos have been postponed and are now
scheduled for release sometime in 2024
as soon as we know more you will be
informed in our weekly news
I'll be back or maybe not those who were
looking forward to the next Terminator
movie with Arnold Schwarzenegger need to
be strong now sadly Arnie has bad news
about the future of his most famous role
no matter how Beloved the first
Terminator films are to this day the
later sequels have never really been
able to keep up with them regardless of
whether it was salvation Genesis or most
recently dark fate the attempts to bring
the franchise back to success in
theaters were rather frowned upon by
fans after the return of Linda Hamilton
as Sarah Connor was unable to turn the
tide in 2019 and even leading actress
Mackenzie Davis did not really believe
in another sequel the terminator's Fate
seemed sealed Arnold Schwarzenegger now
gave a clear statement on the matter in
an interview with The Hollywood Reporter
he also thinks poorly of the later
sequels he was not involved in part 4
because of his political work and parts
5 and 6 had bad scripts something that
was clear to him even beforehand for him
this chapter is now closed quote the
franchise is not done I'm done I got the
message loud and clear that the world
wants to move on with a different theme
when it comes to the Terminator we are
interested to find out whether they will
give it another try with the Terminator
film and what kind of approach they will
take on the project for those who would
rather keep having fun with Arnie there
is plenty to choose from on May 25th the
action series Fubar will be released on
Netflix as well as the Schwarzenegger
documentary Arnold on June 7th the next
action film with him will be the
Thriller breakout which is currently in
the works
this week fast X originally the
penultimate part of the popular action
series was released in cinemas after
many movies and even more action
sequences many people still can't quite
part with the film series as was
reported last week there is now further
news about the future of the franchise
in time for the theatrical release which
should please many fans the reviews for
the current Fast and Furious 10 are
pretty decent so far however the
marketing and production budget for the
10th part has also increased by a
considerable amount which is why those
in charge will probably have to expect
somewhat lower net revenues nevertheless
according to many fans going to the
movies was worth it simply because of
Jason momoa's appearance which is said
to be very reminiscent of the Joker
there is also a big surprise at the end
of the movie which we won't go into
detail about here but what's next for
the franchise the world premiere of the
film in Rome caused a stir with Michelle
Rodriguez and Vin Diesel among others
commenting on the future diesel stated
that studio Universal has seen the
current film and wondered if the story
could be told as a Trilogy Diesel's
co-star Rodriguez supported the
statement by saying that each story has
three acts which is also a big hint for
Fast and Furious 12. so if you like
action-packed popcorn movies you can
probably look forward to two more films
from The Fast and Furious franchise in
the coming years we cannot wait to see
what happens next
fans of tough Devils with a soft spot
for cats can Rejoice filming for Hellboy
the crooked man has been completed after
Hellboy and Hellboy 2 with Ron Perlman
in 2019's Hellboy reboot with stranger
things Star David Harbor attempted to be
big Blockbusters the new movie will rely
entirely on the horror elements of the
comic original comic Creator Mike
mignola announced on Instagram the
rapping of filming and expressed his
excitement about the footage he's seen
so far he said the film is significantly
closer to the comics than the previous
adaptations anyhow the Crooked Man is
his absolute favorite story about the
horned hero the comic was published in
2008 and the author was also involved in
writing the screenplay for the film
adaptation the story is about a small
community in the Appalachian Mountains
in the 1950s that is haunted by witches
Hellboy has to deal with their leader
who has a dark connection to his own
past since the reboot Hellboy flopped
back in 2019 they are trying the genre
approach this time a small but excellent
horror flick are rated of course with a
star-studded cast which doesn't break
the bank but can turn a profit more
easily Jack kessie who has so far
featured in rather smaller movies
besides an appearance in Deadpool 2
plays the lead role the director is
Brian Taylor who among other projects
also directed Ghost Rider 2. to date it
is not known when and where Hellboy the
Crooked Man will be released a
theatrical distribution is just as
likely as a streaming Premiere we are
looking forward to the first moving
images and we'll keep you posted
ever since it became clear that Henry
Cavill will no longer play a part in the
current DCU and will therefore not
return as the man of steel the question
of a suitable successor has come up as
we already know the successor is
supposed to play a much younger Superman
in the upcoming Superman Legacy
according to the Hollywood Reporter four
actors are currently on the shortlist
Netflix star David cornswet the still
rather unknown grantchester actor Tom
Brittany and the also still rather
inexperienced Andrew Richardson the
fourth person is Nicholas halt who was
last cast in Redfield and the menu all
four are and least in terms of
appearance already fitting candidates
for the role of the young Clark Kent the
fan favorite among the contenders so far
however seems to be David korenswept
since he looks most like Henry Cavill
and could almost be his younger brother
Holt meanwhile is at the same time being
considered for the role of Lex Luthor so
he might be in the film either way some
even assume that Superman could have to
deal with Apex likes who was an even
more powerful version of the villain
either way we can look forward to an
exciting new twist with Superman Legacy
especially since DC Mastermind James
Gunn is not only writing the screenplay
but also directing the film according to
Gunn the movie is not about an origin
story but rather about the hard balance
between Superman's life as an alien from
the Planet Krypton and his human
upbringing which makes him a part of
society on Earth with more developments
to come we look forward to the
theatrical release of Superman Legacy on
July 11 2025.
have you not had enough of action films
well perfect as we've got a new original
episode on our Channel about The
Expendables 4 that is scheduled for
release on September 22nd feel free to
check it out and let us know what you
think and if you have any other pieces
of news that didn't make it into our
video be sure to share them with the
community in the comments thanks for
watching and see you next time
[Music]
thank you